so how's retiring to tie the truth
[ __ ] miserable yeah why is that well
because
i mean aside aside from aside from like
my kids
you know aside from you know you
i'm you know with family and you know
when i'm not boxing
i'm [ __ ] miserable [ __ ] miserable
for some strange reason it's like it's
like boxing
like boxing is like my savior it's like
you know boxing
it's that's all i know that's all i know
it's
i started fighting when i was five years
old you know and so
when i'm not thinking about boxing when
i'm not thinking about fighting somebody
or
or training or you know it's like [ __ ]
what do i go do
i'm gonna go [ __ ] destroy my life i
want to go you know
but you're a small guy you can go to
enterprise business
never destroy your life yeah but yeah
but i think more with him mike is what
i'm getting from oscar i think it's more
of like
the high the you know i mean like his
purpose is almost like he
you've done boxing for so long that it's
it's the biggest high that you could get
oh bro but
i mean but you're right mike it's like
okay i mean i have all this business
i have you know it's you know i'm a
smart guy you know i know how
for some reason we have something and
that's built in our head
you know in our heart that that that you
know it's always gonna be okay
you know and you know business is good
family's good you know but it's like
we're always torn in between we're
always like getting pulled here
and then getting pulled here you know
and it's like we have
it's like a balancing act you know how
would you want your life to be a perfect
life for you would be what
wow that that's that's that's you know
it's crazy i've never been asked that
yeah
it's a deep question but uh a perfect
life you know obviously there's no
perfection but
you know a perfect life for me would be
not to be selfish you know
so it's almost like so oscar it's almost
like peace
contentment yeah it's like so do your
selfishness um
and fill you with guilt yeah it's it's
part of that it's part of the guilt
what is your selfishness what is your
your requirement for me
well i mean obviously not always putting
myself first you know
in whatever situation and what it it's
like not not that we're
not that i'm a bad guy or a mean guy or
no
it's just like sometimes you just have
to put people first you know well that's
that's self-preservation how did that
become bad
that's the number one law
self-preservation you can't help
yourself you can't help anybody else
right i wouldn't take that as being
selfish yeah that's a different you need
another that's interesting
that's when i started thinking to myself
like man i must have
i must have a [ __ ] angel looking
looking after me
we all have something yeah yeah
somewhere i don't understand it either
no and
and you do oscar because obviously i've
man i grew up
you know being mexican-american mike
oscar's the highest
the highest of the highest you know what
i'm saying for a mexican american
because
it's not it's not a i'm not pure mexican
i'm mexican american yeah
what are they called like we're not from
there we're not from here we're like
we're just [ __ ] lost
well we just have to find something to
dislike the fight
you know that's just no but you talk
about you talk about your
your guardian angel man i feel like
knowing your story i know your whole
story oscar like i read your
story while i was at the olympics man i
ended up winning gold you know what i'm
saying like
your story is part of my story bro as
crazy as that sounds
but i remember reading reading about you
and you know your mom
you know passing away of cancer in 1990
man and then you're going off
1992 winning the olympic yeah winning
the olympic gold man
you know talk about a little bit about
that and yeah you know what's crazy is
is when he talks about like my mom
passing away and all
it's like it's still it's still it still
hurts you know it's still it's still
here you know and it's been
it's been a while it's been it's been a
long time and i've done a lot of work
to to get over her to not not to get
over her but to
to get over the pain but it's still
there you know and it still eats me and
it still
it still just grabs on to me you know
you know
they call that now many um successful
people that started at nothing suffered
it's called survivor's guilt huh
elaborate on that mike what do you mean
by that i'm usually we're in the streets
and there's guys smarter than us
stronger than us
more connected to us matter of fact
we're afraid of them
and we surpassed them and in our minds
we look so up to them so much and
now they've look we can't even see them
they're bugs now
you know yeah i i understand i
understand
and then you feel guilty yeah how do you
do that and then matter of fact you feel
guilty because
in a way they start to um they start to
dislike you in a way
and you're still nice to them by paying
their bills and doing nice different
but they still even have after all that
they still dislike you because they
can't they're not in position to do that
for somebody
you you know you know you you touch on
an
interesting point mike because i i feel
that same way i feel [ __ ] guilty
guilty because
you know what i'm okay i'm happy that i
have all this like success
right i was able to you know
be one of the few or whatever to to to
to make money and keep it right and make
but but but then it's like i think to
myself
why the [ __ ] do i deserve that oh god
please please please
you know what i'm saying yeah but you do
but
but it's that guilt it's that guilt and
and it just keeps eating you inside and
like i say to myself [ __ ] i'm not smart
enough to [ __ ] no see that's listen
but you just said well i'll let you talk
about that only a good person would say
that but
selfish [ __ ] would never think
that yeah that would never come in his
mind that he's selfish what do you
[ __ ] mean
i'm selfish i care i think about i take
care of me don't i
you know you you know one one one person
i'm not sure who it was a long time ago
told me uh
you know what it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter
what you think or how smart you are what
whatever just make sure you hire smarter
people than you
yeah because if you're the smartest guy
they're in the wrong room
exactly i know that man it's crazy it's
great and it's it's pretty crazy we're
talking about this because
this is like [ __ ] that i've never like i
can even talk about
you know and and and
and to me it's like it's all like
bottled in like
i have so much [ __ ] bottled in you know
at starting with my mother passing away
but it goes way beyond
ever since i was like seven years old
yeah because even though
obviously even knowing your story too
even with your father man because your
father was always
hard on you man and obviously your
siblings were always there to to help
you
you know what i'm saying so i wonder if
it's like the the passing of your mother
like the the strong activity of your
father man like you know what i'm saying
there's a lot man there's a lot in this
like oscar i have a lot of passion for
you know that you're a special person
you do know that right come on don't
come on please have an ego you do not
i i i feel there's something special
there
and when it gets unlocked yeah i want
you to know that don't think you're a
[ __ ] up person you're a very special
person and we need you that's real talk
thank you bro don't beat yourself up
thank you thank you
i i i do beat myself up a lot i know
that's cool man i appreciate that